[Music]
according to a recent study
people amber what's up terry can i ask
you some advice
sure how do you deal with anger like
i feel like 20 20 makes me feel so
overwhelmingly angry that sometimes i
don't know what to do with all of my
anger
well i've been doing this thing where i
focus all my anger on a trivial thing in
the past
does it work yeah let me show you right
now in a segment called
being mad like it's 1999.
this is lonnie i think about her a lot
she didn't deserve what happened to her
and i'm still mad about it
in 1999 she was the subject of city
high's hit song
what would you do you know it it's the
song that goes what would you do if this
was at home it was very popular
city high is a group made up of
claudette ortiz
robbie pardlow and ryan toby fun fact
ryan toby was the little black boy who
sings joyful joyful
and sister act 2 begging a habit the
song is supposed to be a motivational
anthem for single parents who are
dealing with poverty but
it's really just a song shaming a sex
worker for simply taking off her rope
which is exactly what the kids and
sister act 2 were asked to do
for their final performance your teacher
says take off your robes
nails take off your robes do it quickly
come on i don't know just take off your
arms
you remember that movie freaking loved
it in the first verse
the men of city high attend a party with
strippers
one of whom is their former classmate
lonnie
they then proceed to take her outside
and berate her for her life choices
now the idea of a person i haven't seen
in a decade giving me their unsolicited
opinion on my life choices
is grounds for at the very least a [ __ ]
who are you talking to
plus a dick punch amber doesn't that
seem
a little harsh my aggressive feelings
for this fictional song from 1999
absolutely
that's the point so then of course
lonnie defends herself
informing them that she's a single
mother taking care of a child alone
because her baby father is an addict who
is in and out of jail
which is like yes we love a
problem-solving black queen doing what
she can to survive
how did they respond they said and i
quote girl you ain't the only one with a
baby
that's no excuse to be living all crazy
ah yes
it's working i feel the anger
transferring because
what the hell kind of response is that
she then admits that she has been
struggling with suicidal thoughts due to
past
trauma from having to flee her home with
her sister at a young age due to their
father's sexual abuse
okay okay all right i see why dick punch
was the very least
but i'm sure after that they emphasized
oh that's cute that you think that
knowing that information when asked
again by lonnie what would you do they
let her know they would and i quote
get up on my feet and stop making tired
excuses
girl i know if my mother could do it
baby you could do it and it's like
can i speak to your mother because she
needs to beat your
asses if you actually want to help don't
lecture her
tip her more money you broke [ __ ]
my 20 20 brain knows sex work is work
period and
sex workers shouldn't be shamed and
degraded they should be protected and
despite my 2020 brain fully believing
that
my 1999 brain is still like damn
this is a great song remember that song
yeah
what would you do was i at home all
alone
because he's hungry tarek and hamper
went on to sing the complete song
however that would have been too
expensive to air and frankly
it did not sound great so we will fast
forward to two full minutes later
so for you this is just a good time but
for me this is what i call that
and that is how you be mad like it's
1999.
[Music]
you